Mike you got a couple coming on your
Stern right now there's one right here
they might get more interested shark
scientists Dr Mike heightaus and Sarah
casaretto are about to reveal why sharks
seem to attack boats from fishing
trawlers to Tiny kayaks once my cast the
line I'm expecting the moment that fish
hits the water for the Sharks to be all
over it and as he's reeling that in
we're gonna see a lot faster Behavior
okay ready you're good
baits out
that one just bought me okay this one's
coming fast
that shark is coming in hot
it was understood
if you stayed on a boat you'd avoid a
terrifying confrontation with a shark
that's not true anymore
Erica almond was fishing off the Gulf
Coast of Florida on a 34-foot boat when
a great white shark took interest
wow when we first saw the shark as it
came closer we were able to estimate it
to probably about 14 to 16 feet now
we've all seen jaws and we know the
outcome of that great white sharks are
rare in the Gulf of Mexico
counter even more terrifying as the
shark was coming at the motors if it hit
underneath with the prop or on the back
itself you could almost hear the teeth
scrape against the metal of the actual
motor itself
fighting the engine
I thought oh my gosh we're gonna need
new Motors or a paddle to get us out of
here because they're going to be gone
we could not believe what we had just
encountered and been a part of I didn't
know that that was something that sharks
would do wow great white
Erica's encounter is not unique many
boaters have the same Showdown with
sharks
Dr Mike heightaus and shark biologist
Sarah casaretto are off the Florida
coast to investigate why these
frightening interactions take place
you go online these days and you see
more and more videos of sharks biting
boats or just getting uncomfortably
close and the question is is that just
more people with cameras or is there
something going on with the sharks and
that's something we're out here to
investigate
a lot of boating activities involve
sensory stimulation that can actually
pique shark's interests it involves
splashing a lot of time down a boat near
fishing or there's Trum in the water
and all of those things could attract a
shark
off the coast of Palm Beach the water
depth is about 100 feet this is an area
with a lot of boat activity and there's
been reports of shark interactions Ford
is an incredible place for sharks one
reason is we have so many habitats in
such a small area you've got Mangrove
forests along the coast seagrass beds
coral reefs and deep water that comes
close to Shore that means all the
different species that are in these
areas can kind of mix so you've got
nurse sharks lemon sharks bull sharks
tiger sharks even great whites come
through here
they set up shop three and a half miles
off the coast to explore why sharks are
attracted to boats in addition to the
two biologists cinematographer Duncan
break will document the shark's behavior
from below the surface
he's filmed sharks all over the world
and has had his share of boat shark
encounters one of the craziest
interactions I've seen with a shark on a
boat was when we were following a bull
shark that we'd seen cruising along the
coast as soon as we approached it it
decided it didn't want us in its space
and it turned round and just went
straight for the engine and did three or
four bites before it turned around and
swam away at which point we decided we
were going to back off and leave it be
all good Duncan all right
you're clear
team's first mission is to reveal why
sharks suddenly Circle boats we're here
on the spot but no sharks yet
Duncan is in the water with an
underwater comms to relay anything he
observes copy that Duncan so Mike Duncan
wants us to start rubbing that boat
engine
sound travel is an incredibly long
distance underwater and sharks have
amazing hearing so you know if they're
not doing something else that might
attract them in
okay ready to rev he's clearer engines
in neutral revving
looking and I don't see anything do you
see anything from your end
copy that Crystal Clear Water Duncan
your sharks don't have ears like us but
they can still hear incredibly well they
even have special cells on their body
that can feel vibrations whether it's
sound or the movement of animals through
the water
and they think free meal
okay I think we got one coming in right
here
I spent a lot of hours in the water with
lemon sharks there's one thing for
certain no matter the size you've got to
be on guard
there have many
being able to turn right around and
almost by their own tail
lemon sharks are a pretty cool species
you know get to be nine or ten feet long
they're pretty intimidating in size when
you're underwater they're also pretty
intelligent sharks here they've been
trained to run mazes and you can see
when they're underwater and you're
swimming with them they're really
figuring things out but the other thing
about lemon sharks when you're diving at
least with them no sense of personal
space they just kind of bump them
straight past you they're not attacking
they're just going where they go
within minutes two lemon sharks become a
dozen
the only bait in the water a rumbling
engine and Duncan's scuba bubbles
so let me check this area our majority
female hanging out and you never expect
to see the little ones out here
while the Sharks Circle
Dr height house and Sarah reveal why
they believe sharks are biting boats
videos of sharks gnawing on Halls about
Steve menkema and his buddies Jeff
Crilley and Scott Crilley were fishing
off the New Jersey Shore when a great
white decided to show them how its jaws
work
oh my God this thing is huge
[Applause]
we're all set up all excited to catch a
big fish I forgot who saw it first
I remember you saying holy crap this
thing's big massive they're half the
size of the boat his leg comes up on
this side right for the chum bag here
just opens his jaw and grabs it
[Applause]
ate our chum bag like you said like a
Tic Tac Tic Tac
he came right up he's scraping on the
back of the boat his teeth are grinding
into the back it was chomping like this
I don't think he could have bit through
the hole but like the size of him and
the weight of them I think if he really
wanted to he could have pushed in and
swapped the boat
once he got what he wanted
did he just swam away like nothing
happened
monster Majestic shark yeah something
you'll never forget right now once in a
lifetime
oh my god dude
one thing you see in just about every
viral video of sharks attacking boats is
one of these it's a chum bag basically a
mesh bag with bait in it fishermen use
it to attract fish in so they can catch
them we're going to do the same thing
but for sharks so we can study them so
uh we're gonna put this in here off the
back Sarah you can throw yours in now
hey Duncan we're about to put the chum
bags in the water so keep an eye out for
the shark behavior to possibly change
uh
we've just put essentially a meal in the
water for them and they're just trying
to get that so we should see lemon
sharks coming up fighting the chum bag
and appearing to bite the boat but in
reality they're just trying to get the
fish in the bag the sound of the boat
engine draws in a shark but it's the
scent of the bait that wraps them up
[Music]
whoa it pulled it out of my hand luckily
it didn't get any bag but it almost did
so you can see how quick this happens if
you're not expecting sharks around it
could be uh pretty surprising to have
one appear at your chum bag
when we just had the sound of the engine
the Sharks would just cruise and they
were hanging out checking to see if
anything was coming up but once we put
Chum in the water and we put fish in the
water they start going to more of a
hunting mode and that's when their
movement gets quick it gets erratic and
sometimes it can be very unpredictable
aggressive behavior could mean trouble
for Duncan down below
if you see them swarming all around us
definitely gets the adrenaline going all
we have to do is try to make sure you
don't get between them and the food
a chum bag might explain why sharks
swarm boats and also why they sink their
jaws into them as well
Arc missed it bumped into the boat that
could look like an attack in the right
viral video but what's going on is that
the shark's just missing and they have
What's called the nictitating membrane
sharks have this defense to protect
their eyes which is kind of like an
eyelid that closes up some sharks roll
their eyes to the back of their head
because the back of their eye is
actually a lot thicker and denser
and in that moment they're blind
but the last second before it hits the
boat it's kind of losing that sense of
vision and that may be one of the
reasons that we see these sharks
attacking boats
if what they were going for let's say a
chum bag moves because of a wave or the
fisherman pulls it out they still have
the propulsion for it they're gonna
maybe bite the boat and they might just
miss
oh
with so much Chum in the water the
researchers question whether sharks are
too dependent on bait for food
the team will catch a shark and take a
blood sample
with the blood we're breaking it down
into plasma and red blood cells we're
then going to do what's called an
isotope analysis where we look at the
chemical composition of these components
to get a sense of what these sharks are
feeding on and how much of it might be
Chum and bait
the team sets up a catch and release one
two three
the time the shark is immobilized is
kept to a minimum
the way we're trying to catch these
sharks is designed to minimize stress to
the animal we're using a relatively
small circle hook that lets us catch the
shark right in the side of the jaw and
these sharks heal incredibly quickly
this really shouldn't hurt the shark at
all so they're back to their normal
behavior right away
nice the shark has it right now one of
the sharks have got our hook we're gonna
let it run with it so it tires itself
out and it'll become easier too there we
go pull in there it goes okay
we're gonna pick up the buoys here
gently bring the shark up next to the
boat get it swimming alongside
where the scientists are catching uh the
Sharks to tag them and take samples
we've got to be really careful when
we're trying to capture this on film
because the sharks attached with a hook
to the boat effectively so if at any
point that hook Pops that shock can
swing by its tail in almost this 180
degree motion and if we're in the way we
could get caught in the shark's Jaws or
also between the shark and the boats
okay got it
252. awesome
so that's eight feet
what we got here is an eight foot lemon
shark
Cottle veins a little deep because it is
a bigger shark and so Mike right now is
drawing blood and once he's drawing the
blood he's going to give that vial over
to me so that way I can um break it down
to the three components you want to
analyze the caudal vein is the largest
in the tail of a shark
heads up heads up and let it go
always assume they're going to do the
most dangerous possible thing and you
will not be disappointed and you will be
safe got it yep
all we're doing now is getting some
blood from the caudal vein here
there we go good job that'll do the
trick okay Sarah are you gonna stay by
the head I'll come to the Head yep
there you go
okay got it yep so what I got here is
the blood that might just drew from the
lemon shark what I'm gonna do is first
put it in this vial which will make it
easier for me to access with a pipette
when we're taking blood from these lemon
sharks we are able to then do a chemical
analysis that helps us determine whether
or not the food is coming from just the
natural fish in the area or if it's
coming from a fisherman's chum bag
with sample in hand the Sharks released
okay now we're going to get this hook
out
and we're gonna let her go
I've been in the water for lots of shark
releases and you never quite know how
the shark's gonna react okay I'm on
don't get anywhere near that mouth
perfect this one decided to leave its
mark
oh no
no
on the release
the shark was a little bit grumpy
you know it had been measured you know
had had his blood taken it's just like
humans going to the doctors we don't
really like it but it has to get done it
turned around and went straight for the
engine it just took a big bite out the
side of the boat
oh no
we're good there we go I'm a little
spree nice job nicely done
well just look at the damage that shark
caused on on the side of the boat here
it just shows how strong the bite force
of these lemon sharks are it's actually
rip pot the gel coat off a couple of
chunks out of the boat and actually uh
Shredded the rubber of the rub rail
wow it really proves that you know if
these sharks really wanted to mess us up
when we were in the water we wouldn't
stand a chance
sharks circling boats and biting holes
while snatching Chum bags makes perfect
sense
but what about sharks biting boat
engines
in the sea battle between sharks and
boats
the Sharks appear to Target one area
oh God the shark was definitely most
interested in the motors more than
anything it would come under the water
and grab the bottom of the propellers no
way you could hear a loud a large
thumping sound and then a scrape as its
teeth hit the hit the motors and props
themselves
I thought either we're going to lose an
engine or we're going to have to paddle
ourselves top
oh
this isn't a case of missing a Chomp on
a chum bag
these sharks are going out of their way
to gnaw on the metal engine and props we
saw that we could get these lemon sharks
up to the boat just from the sound of
the engine but there are plenty of
videos online of sharks biting engines
and that's not about the sound there's a
lot more going on especially the
creation of electric fields and sharks
have an incredible electroreception
sense it's kind of their superpower all
living things create an electrical
charge a human heartbeat is regulated by
electrical charges that signal muscles
to contract and release
an EKG reads those charges
fish also create electrical signals
signals that sharks can detect these
boat engines are sending out these
electrical signals and sharks have what
are called Empire of lorenzini which are
these little tiny pores around their
snout and particularly around their
mouth area these allow them to detect
electrical signals in the water which is
super helpful when you're trying to get
fish or any sort of animal that's moving
in the water but it can also lead to
confusion when you're around man-made
objects that also emit electrical
signals
it's called Electro receptivity and some
sharks like the great white are so Adept
added they can perceive as little as one
millionth of a volt in the water
that's a tiny fraction of what a common
double A battery generates
Sarah has constructed a test to reveal
how effectively sharks can detect
electrical charges like those created by
a boat engine what we have here is we
have two circuit boards both of them are
powered
Pelican cases we actually have these
switches on the outside to help us
easily turn it off and on and do any
alterations we need what we're going to
do is we're going to place both of these
circuits in the water but one's going to
be on and the other one's going to be
off this will enable us to observe the
Sharks and see how they react and how
they respond to the Circuit that's
emitting an electrical field compared to
the one that's not emitting an
electrical field
Sarah's test should capture a shark's
interest
one last check the one with the arm up
has its power on right yeah so once
they're both in the water I'm just gonna
swim over and I'm gonna put that arm
down so that way it's on and running
okay but otherwise you got them exactly
identical the only difference is this
one's got current going through it
absolutely and the one that is on I
actually already covered the light bulb
up so we know that light's not
awesome so yeah this will be a good test
to see if they're queuing in on electric
Fields rather than something floating in
the water for sure and then we're just
gonna tie them off the side of the boat
my expectation is we're gonna have a
good number of lemon sharks and this is
where they hang out but we might see
bull sharks in pittas Florida so you
never know what might show up
the moment they Splash in
they're vulnerable to the sharks
a diverse vision is limited by the mask
lugging a bulky air tank means fleeing
to escape is out of the question
you have to always assume that there is
the potential for an aggressive
encounter especially when you're diving
with sharks and that's why it's really
important to kind of keep your head on
the swivel be aware of your surroundings
it's better to assume the worst and be
prepared for it than to be taken off
guard
[Music]
company arrives
this time
the two testers are out there are about
10 feet apart
okay and I have not seen
a single check out
[Music]
no sharks anywhere near the other one
but uh
Facebook
Foundation
[Music]
the waterproof battery sending out an
electrical field draws a lot of
attention
the charges from the battery appear to
mimic what a shark's prey creates or a
boat engine emits it would explain why
many viral videos show sharks attacking
boat propellers
foreign
it was pretty incredible to see that
from underwater and you could see the
Sharks knew that both of those boards
were out there and they checked out both
of them but they spent almost all their
time by the electrified that's when they
would get close they would bump it
sometimes not so gently yeah I mean we
can even see it right now they're still
swimming past it they're still checking
it out and what was really neat was also
seeing the different type of behaviors
that was incredible and if you think
about how that relates to boat engines
yeah it probably shows that it is that
electric field that they're zeroing in
on when they bite the motor yeah and
then let alone if there's any other
stimuli going on such as someone fishing
off of the boat that's further
attracting the shark and getting them
into that foraging mindset yeah well I
would say that that was a successful
test
science reveals why sharks attack boat
engines
but what about plastic kayaks and canoes
many of the most frightening viral
videos show sharks attacking kayakers
and canoeists
Matt rosenquist Ben sassy and Chris
Esther are Avid fishermen
they prefer to head out under their own
power
I prefer canoes because of the serenity
you know it's peaceful it's not noisy
with the boat motors the three friends
were about three miles offshore fishing
in the Florida Keys
there were no engines to attract a shark
when
oh my God he attacked us he literally
attacked us
when it first started coming up towards
the boat Matt would say oh I think it's
a nurse shark and then all of a sudden I
see these massive Jaws you see that
came straight at the boat hit it with
all its force and it was not happy
that was a moment that if we had not had
Chris's canoe there it could have been
really really bad
I think Ben even fell into Chris's canoe
that was the confirmation that we were
in for the fight of our life
oh my gosh a bull shark came in charging
just like its namesake well and I
remember the feeling of being kind of
tossed and we're just hanging on for
dear life
oh
bull sharks have very high testosterone
more than a male African elephant in
heat
this one was proving it when you're a
bull shark with that stocky build you're
one of the few sharks in the ocean it'll
eat prey about your own body size
instead of much smaller than you you
know that's a recipe for boat versus
shark run-ins
potential it wasn't a single like get
away from me it was over and over
it would attack and then it would turn
back around and attack watch out I
didn't realize it but my butt went in
the water for a second
it's really easy to just sit back and
enjoy a shark if you're on a 20-foot
vessel but if you're on a small canoe or
a kayak
that can be a little more concerning
there's very little separating you from
the water and it wouldn't take much to
knock you over oh my gosh
it was like one part excitement and then
this other part like
surreal is this really happening
yeah there are a few things that could
attract a shark to a kayak yeah one
would be the silhouette you know for a
big shark like a white shark and that
silhouette May mimic uh what its prey is
for other species the silhouette may be
something worth checking out because
maybe there's other prey around some
floating object but then there are other
sensory inputs too you know the paddle
dipping in if a shark's nearby might be
worth investigating not necessarily you
know flying in to attack but just hey
something novel in the environment I'll
check that out
a kayak lemon sharks and a fishing pole
allow Mike to reveal why a shark might
attack a kayak
all right Mike you head on out with the
kayak and I'll keep an eye on you from
the sky with a drone okay sounds good
all right all right we're sending the
Drone up
right now I'm just keeping an eye on
Mike on the kayak using the Drone
getting a bird's eye view of things
seeing where the sharks are where Mike
is Duncan is below for the underwater
vantage point
as if On Cue
the Sharks arrive
a bit of a homebody in the shark World
lemons prefer a home range rather than
long migrations
a little bit of sound when I put the
paddles in and there's the silhouette
but this silhouette doesn't match the
prey of the Sharks we see around here
let me know if any sharks are coming
well there's one or two who keep a
swimming past Mike on the kayak
you got one coming under your bow just
swimming past you right now Mike
Mike wants to avoid what happened to Ben
Chancey off Stuart Florida Ben's an
experienced paddler who's fished from
kayaks for 18 years
whenever a fish over 300 pounds decides
to go crazy and you're in a kayak
there's nothing you can do
we're off the east coast of Florida and
we're trying to catch the biggest fish
that we've ever caught out of a kayak
we get out there and we catch a Bonita
for bait and then we drop that Bonita
down in something huge grabs it
lo and behold I realize it's a giant
bull shark and I'm like wow we've got a
bull shark on this is crazy
spinning me around it's almost like
being on a roller coaster ride and I'm
getting pulled all around and I'm like I
don't I don't know what's going on
that pulled so hard it felt like it was
gonna flip me right over out of the
kayak and I couldn't hold on to the rod
anymore
there was a moment where I was paused
and I'm like oh I got flipped over
it didn't automatically go I better get
for the boat because I could get eaten
once I realized that fish was still tied
off to my kayak
I'm like I gotta get to the boat so I
swam as fast as I can could I did my
best Michael Phelps impression he might
not look like Michael Phelps but I felt
like I swam as fast as him to get back
to the boat he's still on
you might think that these interactions
are unprovoked but when you look at the
kayaks and canoes there's one common
thread most of the times fishing watch
out
what we saw already is shark's not super
interested in the kayak but we're gonna
ramp it up a little and test the
conditions we see in a lot of those
videos by adding some bait now we don't
have a hook here we've tied the fish on
and I'm gonna throw it out there let's
see what happens
once might cast that line and the fish
hits the water I'm expecting the Sharks
to immediately be drawn to that sound
and as he reels it in follow it because
there is fish blood that's just a free
meal on the end of a line for these
sharks
okay ready you're good
space out we're gonna see a lot faster
Behavior they're going to be really
interested in the kayak and what's the
end of that line Sarah the bait's out
but I can't see anything let me know if
I need to reel right now one's passing
right underneath you Mike nope she's
coming
okay this one's coming fast pulling that
fish Mike
perfect so you can see how fast that
shark is swimming toward the boat that's
exactly the kind of situation where you
could get a shark running into a kayak
not because it wants to bite the kayak
because it's interested in the fish on
the end of a line
yep that was nice and close
the science behind shark behavior
reveals the truth behind most viral
videos
but there are some videos where biology
or chemistry aren't the cause of both
shark encounters
no way sometimes it's personality
not the boaters but the sharks
Carl torrison was fishing just offshore
of Jupiter Florida when he came in
contact with one ornery bull shark
am I going on the beach we were about
this far offshore uh we found we came in
here my dad told me sharks attacking the
boat what's going on every time you grab
the boat the boat would stop then he
came back around and when he hit the
side of the boat it was like a boom
I thought we hit a reef
bull sharks have a reputation for being
a bit more aggressive a bit Bolder and
that's not necessarily untrue
this wasn't about the electricity in the
water this shark was just an angry angry
shark and we were interrupting his day
he attacked the boat and he kept
attacking the boat with with intent to
kill the boat kill whatever he was
abiding the power that he was grabbing
the boat with is unbelievable
that video of the big bull shark
attacking the fishing boat is something
I'm not used to seeing at all
after he hit ate the motor and it was
biting on the motor he actually came by
and hit the side of the boat boom you
were literally moving it was like a
Universal Studios ride but it was so
surreal that it was a shark doing it and
that a shark was that powerful
in our studies of bull sharks we found
that different individuals have
different personalities if you want to
call them that some are bold some are
shy you know not every individual is
going to react the same in every
situation you know maybe these uh guys
came across a big shark that was willing
to attack and uh just decided to go
after the boat I mean it's hard to tell
what the motivation of that shark was
but it certainly was going after them
to observe how bull sharks react to
anything new entering their space
to a known full Hangout
on that video that bull shark is
behaving really aggressively but that
sort of behavior is really rare
especially when you're diving
yeah you know these are big predators
and they can get aggressive but usually
there's a reason for it so we're down
there I'm not expecting to see anything
like that but still we'll stay shoulder
to shoulder keep our eyes on things I
think if there's anything in the area
we're drifting along the edge there
they'll come up with investigators
Duncan will film The Encounter whenever
you jump in the water with bull sharks
you've got to have your wits about you
they're incredibly unpredictable shark
that's always testing you coming from
all different angles you pretty much
have to have your head on a swivel
in addition to having very high
testosterone
bull sharks are thought to be more
dangerous to humans than great whites
Sarah and Mike need to be aware at all
times of how many sharks are around
where they are
wolves
ease into the bull shark space as
observed bull sharks will Ram a boat and
are known to attack humans
[Music]
thank you
surrounded by bull sharks shark
researchers Dr Mike heightaus and Sarah
casaretto gauge the shark's Behavior to
determine if they're in danger
this year
that was incredible and the amazing
thing to me is bull sharks have such a
bad reputation for being aggressive and
I mean they're videos of them spotty
slamming boats but those sharks were
just so calm they were just cruising I
mean I did not at any point feel worried
there is some personality in there too I
mean to see some of the individuals
would come in really close but give
plenty of Spanx and others were just
hanging out really far in the distance
yeah they were enjoying the dive just as
much as we were it seemed it really
shows that you know these animals are
not as a rule super aggressive these are
not animals that you would expect to be
coming in and just attacking a boat for
no reason at all
while the viral videos of shark boat
encounters are intense
no one on a boat or kayak Was Bitten
that changed off the coast of Tasmania
in Australia
that's a really unique little area quiet
area not too much drama happens here in
Stanley it's a historic town and there's
around 700 people that live here at
Stanley full time it's always been a
fishing Village winter in Tasmania the
water is cold and few Venture in for a
swim
a shark attack seems like an
impossibility the incident at standing
was extremely rare occurrence I've never
seen a shark or heard of a shark doing
that before
I know that charts have been cited off
Stanley but I've never heard of uh
sharks attacking a boat or people at all
even so a warning of a large shark in
the area was issued when John arnott and
his son Lucas aged 10 were fishing off
the coast
without warning a shark grabbed the boy
off the boat
and dragged him into the water
within seconds the father dove in to
save his son from the jaws of the
attacker the shark thought to be a great
white let him go in moments
many claimed the boy's life jacket and
heroic father saved his life we hear of
uh Surfers being taken by great whites
but we've never heard of that happening
anywhere in Australia the child was
released from the hospital after being
treated for wounds on his chest shoulder
and head
I believe everybody was a bit numb for a
start because it was just something that
you just never hear about in Australia
I've only had sort of one great white
touch the boat it's more curiosity in
England it's very very unlikely that
you'll get grabbed by a shark off a boat
but I mean it can't happen but it's very
unlikely
it seemed a line was crossed between
shark and human the being on a boat
didn't mean you were safe the reports of
that encounter in Tasmania are like
nothing I've ever heard before a boy was
dragged out of a boat while he was
fishing but we just don't know enough
about what happened it's really hard to
know what was going on in the shark's
head at that time they were fishing
there was that stimuli but it's just
such a weird occurrence it's I've never
heard of something like that happening
before with any type of shark encounters
between sharks and boats will only
increase
fortunately the truth is these aren't
attacks
no way
Mullen its domain
with shark populations all over the
world declining I feel like if you're
lucky enough to have a shark attack your
boat you should just lay back and enjoy
the moment and look at the animal you
are seeing one of the most well-designed
Predators on the planet doing its thing
and if you see anything super cool let
me know the results from the blood
sample from the lemon shark are in it
provides a rare insight into shark and
boat encounters when you look at the
samples and you look at what these
sharks are doing they're not getting a
lot of food yeah we're not really seeing
indications that it's probably
completely changing their feeding
Behavior most likely what's going on is
that these sharks are in the area and
hey maybe get a little bit of free food
here why not take a few tail beats and
go over there and check it out
thank you of course there's more work to
do but the initial indications are
certainly that this is not having a
major negative effect on the sharks
our takeaway for looking at the behavior
of these sharks and all the videos is
that these sharks are not really trying
to attack bugs but they're responding to
stimuli like bait electrical charges
[Music]
and you're not gonna need a bigger boat
thank you